it may not seem like much to most people
but the inch and a half of rain that
fell in Death Valley last Friday was
enough to cause catastrophic damage yeah
look at those cars there Death Valley
National Park closed well the damage is
all cleaned up chief meteorologist Ted
florendo is there
we're here at the Death Valley Inn on
Friday they had so much rainfall here
there were dozens of cars submerged in
that water as you can see cars still
stuck and all that mud and debris once
the water subsided this is the result
these cars still stuck here with all
this rock all this mud is still stuck
all over the cars here now one thing
you'll see too over to the left is the
caterpillar over here that was came in
here earlier to help clear out some of
this but like we said some cars still
stuck in all of that mud back in 2015 we
certainly had the flooding up at
Scotty's Castle but what a lot of people
don't realize is even before the flood
at Scotty's we had some pretty
significant rain in this area that
closed many of the roads in the park one
thing about Death Valley is they don't
have the infrastructure like we have in
Las Vegas where they have miles and
miles of flood channels to divert that
water to Lake Mead here they don't have
that the water comes down water goes
where it wants to go like it did here at
the Death Valley Inn
reporting at Death Valley Ted florendo
live local now
and